hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in 2016 in the
Heinen danjo Grandmaster tournament
between yaniponishi and the ding lyron
now if you are wondering about their
ratings these These are the actual
ratings they had um in July of 2016 so
that's why I use those uh so hope you
don't mind that if they're not their
current ratings but I thought it'd be
more authentic if we did it this way now
uh it is finally official will face
dingling for the World Chess
Championship uh title as uh Magnus has
officially sent a letter to fide where
he declines to defend uh his title and
both Yan and ding were officially
invited uh to partake in the uh 2023 uh
fide uh World Chess Championship and now
if you guys remember Jan won the
candidates tournament very nicely a full
one and a half Point ahead of Dean Weir
and he finished with some nine and a
half dink had eight points and usually
when you win the candidates tournament
your prize is to challenge the world
chess champion however magnets will not
be defending so ding who was actually
second in defeated candidates tournament
now becomes all that much more important
and even Hikaru was very very close if
he got that second place we we could be
having a a Yan versus Hikaru World
Church championship in classical not
just in in fish or random uh but it's uh
it's again questionable if Magnus would
decline the title if he were to face
Hikaru for example I don't know that's
just uh uh you know a a whole different
story uh so I decided to show you one
game uh that was from the serenized
tournament in 2016 it is their first
ever classical game that did not end in
a draw that's all I'm gonna say and it
features a very nice line of the scotch
uh so I'm sure you guys are going to
enjoy that as well so let's dive
straight into it Nepal has the white
pieces and he opens uh the pawn is
already here with Ponte E4 we have Pawn
to E5 Knight F3 Knights the C6 and now
Pawn to D4 the scotch opening or the
scotch game as advert e-captor Sundee
for Knight captures on D4 and now Bishop
to C5 just putting pressure on that
Knight on D4 and now uh Bishop to E3 is
by by far the most popular
a continuation for white but here we
have Knight captures and C6 uh the
second most popular and now B captures
on C6 oh Queen to F6 is also possible
you could just threaten Checkmate in
white white to play Queen F3 trade
Queens uh and then uh grab the Knight on
C6 but if you want to keep the Queens in
the game then just beat captures on C6
with Bishop to D3 by Yan and now Pawn to
D6 and now again the position is a known
one here you will probably see some like
castles Knight the C3 or queen to E2 or
move like that but the move in this game
has never been played before and never
has been played since uh this game
between Nepal and Ding and that is Pawn
to H3 this is what nipple um uh decided
to bring to this tournament and uh
obviously it has a purpose of confusing
ding as it's a very weird move to play
so it is now as of move seven that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how Dean continues he plays Knight the
E7 and already this could be very very
interesting because here the engine
really likes Queen to H4 but this is not
a move you play I mean you don't play
Queen to H4 unless you're like uh Jan
would play Queen to H4 even if he never
saw the position probably but maybe for
ding uh the position that doesn't call
for it the thing is you are threatening
Checkmate and that's not I mean of
course you're not gonna Checkmate your
opponent but it's very tricky how to
continue the game for white uh point
being that if you Castle
you're just lost it's it's that simple
now Bishop captures an H3 G captures and
now of course Queen to G3 check King to
H1 Queen captures and after King to G1
uh it's not all that clear how to
actually finish the attack but the G5
wins the game here beautiful stuff here
I mean it's such a uh such a weird move
to play but uh you know if it works it
works uh now for example to give you
some ideas Bishop T3 of course you want
to eliminate this bishop here Knight H6
you don't care about the bishop if
Bishop counters here in 90 G4 threatens
Checkmate and now after rookie one
clearing the F1 Square for the king
because if now Queen to H2 check you can
run now you're gonna capture uh on C5
and yes you have tripled pawns your
sacrifice the piece for the attack it
doesn't matter white is without a move
there is no good move white can make
here everything is covered uh you can't
bring the queen to F3 you can't bring
the The Rook to E3 then I discovering
that I mean there are no useful moves
here let's say play Queen D2 look at
this C4 4 already The Rook is coming
into the attack Bishop captures Rook d8
Bishop D3 now Rook D6 with Rook to H6
and queen H1 Checkmate so insane stuff
but of course it's not forced so after
this um H3 move uh you could play a
queen H4 but then white would have to
figure out how to how to defend properly
and how to continue the development but
as young brought this variation to the
tournament with H3 that being probably
thought of course Jan knows knows about
stuff like that so ding just played
Knight to E7 we have Knight to C3 and
now we have Knight to G6 we have Knight
to A4 now it is uh important to get rid
of this bishop so Bishop D4 C3 and
Bishop to F6 okay you do not win the
bishop but at least you you've gotten
the bishop off of this diagonal and
finally we have Castles by nepo we have
Knights the E5 now attacking the bishop
and just Bishop to E2 so both players
keeping their Bishop pair uh alive uh
kingside castles biting and now Pawn to
F4 and why wouldn't you the Knight has
to go somewhere Knight to D7 and now
Queen to C2 nicely developing the queen
then the bishop and then the Rooks will
be connected with fonta C5 the Knight
here isn't uh really doing all that
great but if you think about it this
Knight really isn't doing all that great
either the bishop is an F6 you can put
it on F6 even if you could maybe you
wouldn't want to maybe just give white a
very valuable Tempo uh you can't really
do all that much with it so probably you
will put it to B6 at some point
and then uh Jan will just trade this
Knight for this night so Bishop to F3 uh
putting the bishop on this diagonal Rook
the B8 and not Bishop T3 continuing
development and now again there are many
ways you could continue this you could
play some like Knight to B6 right away
you could play best of T6 you could even
start with a nice move like G5 also
possible uh it's a idea being that you
want to capture on your for placing h8
and put the Rook on the G file to put
pressure on a white skiing side but the
thing not feeling like playing that kind
of a game goes the best of the A6
attacks The Rook Rook after D1 and now
we have Queen to E7 makes sense as you
do not want this Rook aligned with your
Queen Bishop back to F2 and now Bishop
to B5 now putting pressure on the Knight
here and it seems like ding wants to
capture an A4 and then after Queen
captures play Rook captures on B2 but
this isn't a a very a very good thread
for example let's say you play rookie
one you prepare E5 at some point Bishop
captures Queen captures and Rook
captures it looks like very good for
black you've gained control of the
second rank but look at this E5 and now
after d captures an E5 Queen captures an
A7 with uh C7 hanging you can't capture
here because the queen is on E7 it's uh
not not all that impressive for black
and also white just has a fast Pawn
white can start pushing that pass Pawn
so uh you know maybe in some lines but
it's not the a concrete threat but still
Nepal plays Rook 8 to B1 we have Knight
the B6 and now he does trade this Knight
uh that was on the rim for the entire
game for this Knight on B6 so captures
captures and now Rook to E1 uh in case
some of you were only listening and not
watching that was a characters and B6
not C characters and B6 so here we have
Bishop to C4 putting pressure on the A2
pawn and now Pawn to B3 attacking the
bishop on C4 Bishop back to E6 and now
Pawn to A4 we have Rook after d8 also
you could consider something like G6 if
you consider uh F5 to be a threat but
adjust the Rook after d8 biting and now
comes Pawn to B4 and now it looks like
you are threatening A5 which will
definitely create a past Pawn so ding
just Place Bishop to C4 now you don't
really care about A5 because A6 is
guarded and if a A5 a a captures and B6
then you will happily undouble your C
Pawn so it's not a problem so B captures
and C5 by on this is a beautiful move
that trades down into a wonderful
wonderful position for him look at this
B captures on C5 Rook counters on C8
Rook captures on C8 and now Pawn to E5
just breaking through here D captures F
characters now of course it seems like
you could capture this but then I mean I
uh uh how are you surviving this the
bishop captures on E5 uh a nice Queen to
E4 attacks the bishop twice now and also
the bishop and C4 is attacked so instead
after F captures an E5 Bishop to G5 is
played and now we have Pawn to A5 Nepal
just starts advancing his past Pawn
instead of A5 I will just mention it
because it's really a nice slap in the
face there is this move H4 and it's just
a very ugly move to meet because it
forces Bishop to an even a less
favorable Square it forces the bishop to
H6 point being now that if Bishop
captures an H4 you can just trade and
there's a rookie for winning the bishop
on C4 so you're gonna have to move the
bishop back to H6 which is not all that
great so maybe a slight Improvement A5
G6 Now by Ding and this was uh Queen to
E6 was a little bit better you want to
cement your control over the over the A6
Square G6 does not do all that much Jan
plays Queen E4 now puts pressure on the
bishop on C4 Queen to E6 defending the
bishop and also keeping an eye on that
A6 square and now comes Bishop captures
on C5 now instead of these Bishop
captures on C5 I will also just mention
one incredibly beautiful line because
this is classical so you know we are
here to enjoy beautiful lines look at
this bishop G4 move it seems like it's
doing a whole lot now if the queen moves
you're gonna push E6 you're gonna ruin
Black's King side and then you're gonna
just win the game easily however what
happens if Pawn to F5 probably what
happens is you're gonna have to
calculate a lot what happens here and
probably everything gets traded off and
you have an end game that's maybe not so
certain however it is completely winning
look at this e captures on F6 Queen
captures an E4 Rook captures an E4 and
now how do you how do you play this
doesn't really matter let's say you play
Rook the B1 with check uh White will
just block Rook D1 and after captures
and captures now how do you defend uh
you could either go for this Pawn or you
could go for this pawn and uh none of it
is uh really good if you capture or play
something like King to F7 just Bishop to
C8 you gain control over the A6 where
you're gonna push A7 A6 A7 and A8 uh
bring your queen into the game and win
the game there is no way to defend the
dark squares as your pawns are blocking
the dark Square so this would just be
completely winning for white and another
thing after this bishop captures anyone
if you don't go after the F Pawn if you
go for some like Bishop to A6 you
blockade the pawn you cover the C8
Square now look at this bishop to E6
check now all of these squares are
covered King fate F7 and now the problem
for black is there is no way to control
all of the dark squares because you can
reach the black in just so many ways and
Jan just so happens to have a a dark
Square Bishop so yeah even if you don't
do anything just Bishop G3 for example
captures and Bishop D6 check we will end
the game and if you try something like
Bishop to F4 to try and control all of
the squares it's still not possible just
Bishop F2 goes after this pawn and once
you prevent this with Bishop to D6 now I
just play Bishop P3 you go after Bishop
H6 like I said impossible to control all
the dark squares so uh this was quite a
move Bishop to G4 but the young goes for
Bishop captures on C5 it's still
incredibly difficult to defend whether
it's winning by force most likely uh
it's just that this one was uh you know
very easy to see why it's completely
winning so here Ponte H5 by Ding and now
Bishop to D4 we have rooked the B3 and
now comes Rook to A1 of course but not
allowing some like Rook E3 to put the
Rook behind the pass pawn and now you
are ready to push we have pawned the C5
by ding attacking the bishop and Indian
just laughs in his face and pushes Pawn
to A6 of course the bishop and D4 cannot
be captured if you capture it pawn to A7
and pawn to A8 ends the game so after A6
with Bishop captures and A6 and now
Queen the A8 with check and that's why I
said the other line uh was better
because it's outright just winning and
this way you allow ding to find some
defensive Maneuvers and here if ding
finds King to G7 he will probably defend
the game for example if King to G7 now
how do you play Bishop D5 you attack the
queen and the Rook Queen the B6 now
we're gonna capture The Rook on B3 but
now C captures on D4 let's not forget
that bishop and D4 is hanging Queen
captures an A6 now Queen captures on B3
and after C captures on D4 it looks like
okay Rob The Exchange you have a d Pawn
you have an E Pawn uh the problem is
there's Queen to E3 check and after King
stage one Queen captures on D4 and now
white has nothing better than the play
E6 this is the only attempt at winning
the game F characters and you have this
position where white is up the exchange
but black just might have enough
compensation uh with the semi-open uh
White King's position uh you might not
be able to to just end the game you if
you put both the queen and the Rook into
the attack then you might not have
sufficient resources to defend against
all of the checks black can give so
something to consider but instead of
King to G7 Dean played Queen to C8 offer
the queen trade and now look at this
Rook captures on A6 first young grabs
the bishop and now Rook to B8 and now uh
the Jan's Queen on A8 is hanging and the
problem is there is only one move that
wins the game for Yan uh and it's a
really funny one so feel free to pause
the video and win this game for Yan
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on paying attention
because yes our Bishop on D4 is still
hanging and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop to
F2 the only winning move so
congratulations to everyone who found
this it means that you can just you know
get out of the position you know forget
about the Queen Annie that's sort of
hanging it's not really hanging but yeah
you have to find Bishop to F2 so
congratulations to everyone who was able
to do this and now you you don't really
have a move with white if you capture
the queen then just rook recapters and
the black king Falls as well as the
bishop covers the A8 Square so there's
really nothing better captures captures
and you're just up a full light Square
version so of course this is completely
winning for ding so instead after Bishop
to F2 ding plays King to G7 now but
that's uh you know King King to G7 a few
moves too late uh Queen to C6 now
getting the queen out of Harm's Way
offering a queen trade and here Rook the
B1 with check King to H2 and now Queen
the F5 going after that E5 5 Pawn but
here or instead you could play Bishop F4
check with just G3 or Bishop G3 there is
nothing here so instead Queen F5 uh
nipple blade Queen to E4 and it was in
this position on move 40 probably when
time control was reached um uh that
dingler and resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here now you
either trade Queens which is not really
good you're down a full piece if you
move the queen you lose the Rook uh here
so there is nothing any Bishop therefore
check again you okay you can grab one
Pawn but it's not enough captures
capture still it's I mean a full bishop
or a completely resignable uh so after
this Queen T for move ding resigned and
Jan nipponishi uh wins the game and he
wins the his first ever game against uh
dingler and In classical time format uh
up until this point in 2016 ding has yet
to win a single game against the In
classical time format which is not that
easy if you've seen uh how young plays
chess even uh before the World Chess
Championship match she was one of the
one of the actual few people who had a
positive score against Magnus Carlsen In
classical after the world championship
match that kind of changed because there
were a lot of decisive games there uh
but yeah really good stuff so it's a fun
game uh oh pretty much all of their
classical games are fun and I think
we're gonna have a really really
interesting World Chess Championship
Match uh so we'll see uh we'll see what
when it happens uh we don't know a whole
lot about the world's championship match
2023 but I will keep you guys informed
as soon as uh you know anything goes
public
uh so yeah uh that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it uh like I said first
ever game uh with a with a not another
draw result between the two of them so
hope you enjoyed that uh I would like to
thank Nathan Halsey Jacoby the more
chess 960 ergon Carlo marovo and the
Martin girl paparik for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day